hey everybody welcome to the podcast my
guest today is dr. Michael Greger making
his fourth appearance on the show most
people know Michael as a nutrition
expert he's the man behind such
best-selling books as how not to die and
how not to diet as well as the founder
of nutritionfacts.org less well-known is
the fact that earlier in his medical
career Michael worked in public health
with focus on infectious diseases and he
is a guy who's been sounding the
pandemic alarm for well over a decade at
this point on that note he recently
released a new book it's called how to
survive a pandemic and the focus of
today's conversation is on all things
coronavirus what causes pandemics what
can be done to prevent future pandemics
the current state of affairs and what we
should all be mindful about right now
when it comes to self-care and looking
after others this one is packed with so
much solid grounded information I think
you guys are going to love it if you
enjoy the content that we work hard to
put out every single week do me a solid
hit that subscribe button and with that
I give you one of my very favorite
people the great dr. Michael Greger
[Music]
back in the house ready they're rich and
roll so good to see you I feel like I
just saw you but it was a little while
ago I wasn't the world was very
different
pandemic John it's all out the window
what's super interesting about you is
that we all know and love you as this
nutrition specialist expert the man
behind nutritionfacts.org but actually
you earlier in your career had this
whole path in public health specializing
in emerging infectious diseases and
you've been shouting from the
mountaintops about pandemics for over a
decade so here we are and suddenly that
book that you wrote back in 2006 is more
relevant than ever you've got this new
book out so I can't wait to just roll up
our sleeves and get into what exactly is
going on right now well yeah I mean the
first half of my professional life was
all emerging infectious diseases in fact
I mean that's most of my scientific
publications that's how I got an old
broad that's how I got on you know all
that I mean that that was really that
was and no one was listening right I
mean yeah yeah in fact the whole public
health community was warning people
about the coming pandemic no one
listened I was like alright um you know
I'll have it let me let me default to
the leading cause of death every single
year from from 1919 to 2019 for the last
hundred years always realize in the back
of my mind well you know the reason that
heart disease wasn't the leading killer
for last 101 years because in 1918 there
was a pen am i blue right the next ones
coming and when it comes alright then
I'll find them maybe when people listen
um I'll be able to delve back and that's
how I was able to you know scribe to
write a book in such a short time was
because the researchers done and it was
just a matter of you know throwing
together a few chapters on that on the
current situation right and you know
well the first book was really focused
on bird flu right do you think if at
that time people really perked up and
paid attention that that would have
shifted your whole career trajectory you
would have stayed in that field I think
so yeah I mean because
I mean it's as critically important
today as it was back then in fact the
leading candidate according to the CDC
of the next pandemic after Kovan is a
bird flu virus by the name of h7 and 9mm
which is a hundred times deadlier then
covered 19 is that the one with fifty
percent no it only has a forty percent
right we're telling you it's so h5n1 I'm
was higher but has has dwindled as h7n9
has taken to the forefront of a global
spread so that's the leading candidate
although h5n1 still may be waiting in
the wings of chickens of course my 879
seems to be the most likely and so
instead of one 250 people dying at 200
times deadlier 40% and so you know as
devastating as co19 has been to lives
and livelihoods around the world you
know uh you know imagine a pandemic you
know that you know the every other
person right so the well so you know uh
you know 1918 I had a two percent
fatality rate mm-hmm and so yeah but
imagine a pandemic where billions are
infected but forty percent people right
and that was and that was the last time
a bird flu virus jump directly to humans
and tiered pandemic it caused the
deadliest plague in history the 1918
riot and so it's you know you know it's
it's just uh it's just a matter of time
and so but there so the good news is
there's some we can do about it mmm you
know just like closing down live animal
markets and you know the wild animal
trade will reduce the risk of future
coronavirus pandemics reforming the way
we raise domestic animals for food may
help forestall the next well that's a
good place to start
you know the very root cause of what's
leading to these pandemics that you know
ultimately are an inevitability so let's
start there I mean we're all kind of
familiar with what triggered kovat with
the pangolins i guess that's the
reigning theory of the moment
- how this began but there's a larger
issue at play here which is the
institutionalization of animal
agriculture and how we're creating you
know on a systemic basis the breeding
ground for the next pandemic and the
next pandemic and you know perhaps much
more virulent strains of a virus that
are gonna be far more deadly here over
the last few decades human pathogens
have emerged at a rate unheard of in
human history and as we emerged from
where mostly from animals so you know
HIV it's been traced back to the
butchering of primates and the bushmeat
trade in Africa mad cow disease it was
because we turned you know cows into
carnivores and cannibals SARS in cove at
19 and traced back to these exotic live
animal markets but you know our last
pandemic swine flu in 2009 arose not
from some backwater wet market in Asia
but was largely made in the USA right
here on industrial Pig operations in the
United States now thankfully so when I'm
full only killed about a half million
people but the next time we might not be
so looking well just came out that last
week this new story about pigs in China
and and a couple slaughterhouse workers
getting sick yeah this is very alarming
so it's actually yeah it's actually a
new mutation oh that very swine flu
virus this durable hybrid mutant which
contains genes from both human Pig and
avian flu z' that was new enough to the
human immune system that was able to to
spread around the globe and is still
with us to this day as a seasonal flu
but but all it has to do is you know
change enough to kind of overwhelm the
pre-existing immunity but but yeah so so
but we happen to pick the two species
that are that are vulnerable to the
virus the only known virus on the planet
capable infecting billions of people
within months of time and that's
influenza and so most species actually
or don't get the flu very few species so
it's pigs and it's Birds Anakin's - or
chickens or something chickens yeah no
it's a
chickens emerges in waterfowl um but in
fact as a waterborne innocuous aquatic
virus and only travels to the lungs when
placed in a land-based predator estriol
bird like chickens and how would the
duck and a chicken ever get together a
live animal markets its awareness to
pack them both together and once the
virus finds itself in the guts of a
chicken it no longer has the luxury of
easy waterborne spread where chickens
aren't paddling around in the pond also
it's a fecal oral route in ducks and
waterfowl as it existed for millions of
years before we domesticated ducks once
it finds a way into a chicken it needs
to mutate or die it has to find a new
way to travel and on does that by
changing to an airborne virus actually
infects the lungs and that makes it that
much more risky for terrestrial mammals
such as ourselves so what yeah it goes
into you know chickens as this harmless
virus comes out as the flu uh-huh and
what is it specifically about kay foes
animal agriculture that's fomenting this
is it just the crowded conditions is it
the way that they're you know immersed
in their fecal matter is it the way that
they're fed are treated like what are
the contributing factors all the buffs
and when we take thousands of animals oh
I mean Cremonese you know filthy
football-field-sized sheds till I beat
to beat course not just now to top their
own waste it's just a breeding ground
for disease right it's not just the
sheer numbers the overcrowding but the
you know the stress crippling their
immune systems the ammonia from the
decomposing waste burning their lungs
the lack of fresh air like a sunlight
put all these factors together well you
have is kind of the super storm kind of
environment for the emergence of spread
of this perfect storm environment the
emergence part of super strains of
influenza tragically we don't tend to
shore up the levees until after disaster
strikes and the bottom line is it's not
worth risking the lives of millions
people for the sake of Cheaper chicken
mm-hmm and I suspect that when you have
so many of these animals in these types
of conditions that that then creates a
situation in which
you're kind of exacerbating the
potential for mutation right because if
it's getting spread amongst that
population then there's an exponential
amount of it and so it's replicating
more rapidly
it's like crowding a thousand pigs in an
elevator right one of them sneezes like
what do you expect would happen it's
really the perfect if you want if you
were a mad scientist and wanted to breed
a deadly uh you know flu virus this is
exactly the kind of conditions where you
do in fact they actually do these
so-called serial transmission studies in
a lab where when you want to make a
pathogen more deadly more lethal more
virulent what you do is you pass it from
animal to animal normally virulence is a
control there's a there's a there's a
there's kind of a balancing act a
teeter-totter between virulence and
transmissibility if the that's why in
its natural state
influenza is completely harmless ducks
never get sick no waterfowl get sick
because a dead duck can't fly that virus
wants to get to the next lake how does
it do that by completely being an
oculist harmless no symptoms the duck
doesn't even know it has it and just
multiplies in the intestinal wall and
and goes on okay but only when forced
into environment where there's no cost
to the virus to get very odd I mean the
the virus would like to give me very
more violent the more virulence is the
more can produce titers of virus you
have a huge viral load but it has to be
really really quiet about it because it
might not spread as far but as soon as
you remove that restriction remove that
constraint when a virus can knock you
like a two-by-four and still transmit to
the other because you're so backed up
something right now because even
immobilize hosts can spread when that
happens then there's no limit to how
virulent the virus came together and
that's what we had in the trenches of
World War one which is where we think
the 1918 virus emerged from the trenches
and basically from the virus's
standpoint those same trench warfare
conditions exist today in every
industrial chicken shed in every
industrial egg operation confined
crowded stress but by the billions
not just Millions that's fascinating
yeah I never thought about it in those
terms normally yes the virus would not
want the host to perish because then the
virus perishes but when there's a
population of you know hundreds of
thousands of these animals
what's one dead animal if it can jump to
the next one and continue to populate so
there's an evolutionary advantage
there's a selection pressure to get even
more violent to kill the animal quicker
to make this violent hacking cough I
mean to each other and so it just
ratchets up but only in those kind of
rare circumstances and either in the lab
where you can literally dose an animal
you you stick a needle down their throat
and then um and then you can take take
their lung so you grind them up into
blender and you stick that needle down
another animal but you do that you do
that ten times you can and you don't
take harmless virus turned into a lethal
virus kills 100 percent of the animals
because which virus is selected for when
there's guaranteed transmission to the
next one the one that that out can beats
the others mm-hmm right otherwise
normally it would you know if if in the
millions of years where influenza
existed naturally if some crazy mutant
strain came up that was more it would
instantly be selected against and die
there with that animal because it's just
not gonna spread much farther I just
created this system to create you know
virulent particularly virulent pandemic
so or we may always have pandemics but
there's a difference between a pandemic
with a point for case fatality rate one
250 people died and something like like
so called category 5 pandemic that's the
CDC's has a pandemic severity index
similar to those like hurricanes
severity index with categories one
through five and a category 5 pandemic
starts at 2 percent mortality so 19 is
there's only been one category 5
pandemic of 1918 and that's but that's
just where category 5 starts at 2% Wow
and so covitz kovetz uh - right no
kovetz point 4 oh ok what a category
what category is it in so oh so so that
makes it a category 1 pandemic right now
we are in a category 1 pandemic which is
less Academy sorry category 2 bitten
having point yeah under point 5 mmm so
we are category 2 pandemic and and never
before has there been flu viruses with a
fatality rate on order of something like
Ebola or untreated HIV I'm so you have 2
worst of my something like the common
cold a respiratory virus easily
transmitted infecting a significant
percentage of the population within
months and a virus with just
unprecedented lethality with h5n1 8 7
and 9 and 10 other bird flu viruses that
have emerged completely unknown in the
last few decades ever since we started
exporting or Tyson model of industrial
poultry production to South Asia it's
terrifying it's absolutely terrifying
what what determines the jump to humans
how does that work because we're you
know we hear about these wet markets in
Asia and that's really about one species
to another species and then a subsequent
jump to humans right right and so right
for the there's been three deadly
coronavirus outbreaks SARS MERS denkova
19 and they all seem to have a fall it
seemed to involve this transitional
species starting and in bats the
reservoir species just like for
influenza it's ducks and waterfowl house
I think but yeah but the virus is so far
removed from something that can affect
humans there has never been a single
reported kind of human clinical
infection from adopt virus I mean they
all all influenza viruses where I'm from
duck there's one case of someone
cleaning out a duck bar and got a piece
of straw in there I get a little
conjunctivitis little pink eye it's the
worst a duck virus has ever been able to
do only through these land-based
terrestrial birds like quail and chicken
um is the virus able to mutate into the
flu that a respiratory pathogen that can
infect humans and pigs another
can a land-based mammals so in
coronaviruses bats are the original and
the reason why bats and ducks are I have
these heard viruses is because they
congregate in massive in this huge herd
some root bat roost in colonies can be
half million mm-hmm bats together and
only under those kind of circumstances
can you get a can you get a viral
pathogen able to infect large
populations because normally if there's
just small colonies of various animals
everyone gets immune to the virus the
virus dies so that you don't have so you
can't really have kind of a herd virus
but when you have these massive colonies
of hundreds of thousands of ducks are
bats they can develop they can start
basically an infection on one side go
all the way to the other side of the
population and then this one loses
immunity back and forth and it can exist
so in bats we have this corona viruses
but it takes but people aren't getting
affected directly from bats there's an
intermediate species kind of halfway
between kind of stepping-stone species
between bats and people in the case of
SARS it was this cat-like creature
called the civet cat raising these live
animal markets the case of MERS the
Middle East respiratory syndrome viruses
camels bats - camels - people at a desk
of a nineteen leaving candidate for the
intermediate species as these penguins
these scaly anteater type creatures
again I'm in these a live animal markets
where you can get this kind of
confluence of unusual species that
you've never really get together in
nature and can create these viruses with
mm-hmm
and what is the degree of difficulty for
you know the virus that's you know being
harbored in the chicken farms the pig
farms - jumping to human it's like what
are we looking at in terms of you know
we've had swine flus etc we've never
seen a true pandemic emanate out of
factory farming yet I mean you're
painting a thousand nine so that 2009
was our first factory farm pandemic we
just got lucky
that was there is a narrative that that
came out of China though but did that
actually come out of United States was
actually factory farms or was the or
sorry there out of eighteen so influenza
viruses influenza virus has an segmented
genome there are eight genes I mean six
out of the eight came from a triple
mutant hybrid this was a never before
described bird swine human virus a virus
with genes from all three species that
arose in North America I mean in fact
the first the double hybrid first was
discovered in this factory farm
gestation crate facility of pregnant
pigs in in Newton Grove North Carolina
um very rapidly this triple hybrid
mutant spread throughout North America
and then we exported it to Mexico we
exported it around the world
um where it mixed with a Eurasian swine
so to create the pandemic Wow about six
out of eight of the the pandemic virus
came was birthed in here in North
America well given that factory farming
is essentially how you know most
Americans are getting their food and the
prospect that this is a breeding ground
for future pandemics what do we do I
mean is there a solution short of
eradicating this entire system you know
I want to talk about Cory Booker and and
Elizabeth Warren's new bill that they
just proposed to a rat I'm not sure
exactly what the details are the the
farm system reform act and what's packed
into that but you know what is the path
forward what is the solution to this
knowing that we can't flick a switch and
end factory farming overnight how do we
get on on you know the right side of
history with this so well important to
realize that the public health community
has been has a consensus so the American
Public Health Association which is the
largest and oldest Association of public
health professionals in the world came
out over a decade ago calling for
moratorium on factory farms no more
factory farming so the public health
community has recognized the risk and
has been shouting from the rooftops and
no one's been listening so this is I
mean this is this is what the public
health community understands to be the
rest not only for the emergence of
antibiotic resistant bacteria but
because of the threat of pandemic flu
both from
production and from pig production and
certainly there are things we can do to
reduce the risk so for example we have
there studies showing that just
providing straw bedding for pigs so they
don't have the immunosuppressive stress
of lying on bare concrete their whole
lives it significantly reduces swine flu
transmission rates the Pew Commission on
industrial farm animal production came
out specifically against these extreme
confinement practices like the gestation
crates for pregnant pigs these kind of
veal crate like boxes that are more pigs
pregnant pigs have kept for four months
at a time and specifically because of
the human health risk of putting animals
under these kind of conditions right and
so you know these are the the animals
needles social distancing frankly they
could use for anything wrong at this
point but if we really want to eliminate
this threat we really have to accelerate
the movement away from animal
agriculture towards plant-based milks
plant-based meats plant spaces egg
products and for those of you thinking
that such a move is a pipe dream
have you looked at a dairy case lately
right major US dairy companies declaring
bankruptcy because of crashing fluid
milk cells because of this preponderance
of new consumer choices and we're seeing
that same kind of increase in consumer
choices in the meat aisle as well and
ironically who is leading this charge in
innovating us out of this precarious
situation Tyson Perdue Smithfield Hormel
jbs the largest meat packers in the
world all right now have a plant-based
um meat products hmm how now jbs the
largest me backer in the world just came
out with their own line a blend base you
know Smithfield is partnering with KFC
in China to put plant-based chicken
nuggets on the menu I mean these are so
this isn't
like the Topher keys of gift for some
vegetarian niche product right they are
recognizing particularly with the the
pressures on them on the you know the
source chain that this pandemic has
shown it's more profitable
it's your less labor cost less food
safety issues I mean all down on down
the risk of the externalities of
business as usual they see the writing
on the wall and they're rearranging
themselves as protein companies rather
than meat companies and so that so
they're the ones that that are really
leading the charge in terms of putting
these these products into the hands of
kind of you know regular you know
regular consumers and now from a
personal health standpoint you know be
better if they just eat some black beans
but from a pandemic threat standpoint
zero risk yeah I think it's it's
imperative that these companies pivot
and evolve they're just responding to
market pressure and consumer demand they
see that this is the direction that
people are moving in they understand
that they're gonna quickly become
antiquated unless they diversify their
product line and it's working and that's
why they're doing it right we all hear
about the beyond meets and the
impossible foods but it is interesting
that these stalwart you know gigantic
conglomerates that have been around
forever are also waking up to this
reality and making these pivot shifts
yeah the question is are we gonna do it
fast enough well I mean the clock is
ticking I mean that's why and but if
they're so what we needed is some kind
of kick in the pants some kind of dress
rehearsal some kind of fire drill to
wake us out of our complacency right
uh-huh and to really rethink the food
system and if frankly if this doesn't do
it right that's it fun I don't know if
it is it well but I mean you would hope
it would unite us it would really take
something like this serious enough to
really get people to rethink ways in
where did this come from what can we
prevent future much potentially worse
threats down the road but now the idea
of upend em
it's not some just you know something on
policy papers and people been yelling
about in the side literature now it's
real life yeah and so and we can and and
we can see what kind of viruses are in
the pipeline and realize it look even
more innovative approaches I mean for
those out there who are like you can you
can yank that pork chop from my cold
dead hands is the cultivated meat
revolution the thought that look which
Winston Churchill wrote in this 1932
Popular Mechanics article you know will
we will escape the absurdity in fifty
years of growing a whole chicken just to
get a wing or a breast or whatever well
now that we're making real meat with
animal cells we write with muscle cells
right why make why make a skeleton why
make all that stuff here and eat and
again from a personal standpoint right
meat is meat hmm I'm certainly from a
food safety standpoint to be safer I
mean there's do you don't have to worry
about intestinal pathogens like e.coli
Salmonella when you're making meat
without intestines ready don't have to
cook the crap out of meat it's there's
no crab to begin with right and just
like you don't have to worry about
brewing up new respiratory viruses when
they're you're making meat without the
lungs right and so that may that that's
another route to to escape us from this
sort of Damocles dangling over us which
hopefully finally people will recognize
yeah well a year ago the Booker Warren
bill would have seemed preposterous but
here we are the world is very different
people are paying attention to this in a
new and different way we all saw the
news articles when the meat producers
were putting out you know ads about or
there were articles coming out about the
supply chain problems and the threat to
the workers and there was this sort of
conversation around should these people
go back to work should they not I was
looking at videos of some of these
slaughterhouse workers who are basically
putting themselves in harm's way and
frustrated that the meat packer
employers were not enforcing some level
of social distance or kind of health
standards to protect its workforce like
this is you know also about those
workers who are you know in peril as a
all of this and I think it is good that
we are talking about these things what
do you know what the the Booker Warren
bill is proposing so it's real it's
proposing reforms like the elimination
of some extreme confinement practice we
etchant would help I mean so anything um
you know reducing broiler stocking
density mm-hmm
[Music]
you know with in terms of meat type
birds I mean and we can show in
laboratory settings you double the space
per bird and you can dramatically drop
influenza transmission rates in these
birds and so I mean look you know
anything
all right the situation is so dire
anything is better to do and this is the
time to have this opportunity and look
right now is the last ever at this point
the last thing we need to do is prop up
the meat industry even for the current
pandemic I mean look at the
comorbidities the underlying health risk
factors increasing one's risk of couple
19 severity and death type 2 diabetes
heart disease obesity high blood
pressure all of which can be prevented
arrested or even reversed with a healthy
enough plant-based diet I mean look you
don't even have to be obese just being
overweight put at a BMI of 28 puts you
at the nearly six times the risk of a
severe course of cover 19 so that's
being about 175 pounds at the average
average American height it's nearly six
times the risk of a severe course you
know the average BMI in the United
States twenty-nine
so being skinnier than the average
American could still leave you with so
much excess body fat that put you in
nearly six times the risk Wow um and yet
so you know so so this is the time to
you know if you're ever going to start a
exercise program or stress reduction or
get your sleep schedule right or you
know reduce stress or start eating
healthy this is the time let's take
advantage for those of us who are
privileged enough not have to have to be
out on the front line to you know clean
up our act and not only protect us
against the current infectious disease
set but from chronic disease threats in
the future I want to get into some of
those practices but before we do that I
want to talk about where we're at right
now
we're looking at the potential of
thousand new cases a day we I think
we're at 40,000 as of yesterday you know
anybody who's looked at any of these
graphs is seeing this you know spike
upward that's relative you know it's
pretty alarming clearly we've done a
poor job at containing this it's been
you know a political disaster a public
health disaster where what is your sense
of where we're at
how we've handled this and what we
should be doing not just a poor job but
the poorest job
I'm in the world over so you look at I
mean you don't have to go you know dig
up you know South Korea and Singapore
and Australia you know and you know
these things look the look at Europe for
example about the similar population as
the u.s. Western Europe and they had
they they they they they they you know
got caught unawares just like everybody
and had the spike but came back down
they truly have a wave right we're
talking about is there gonna be second
wave the first wave in the nights are
still in a West way we're still in the
first wave and so if you look at the
pandemic the the epidemic curves around
the world they go up they come down even
with comparable population sizes except
the United States which continues to
rage on but you know you look at you
know Japan where you know oh my god they
had 10 deaths or you know Australia a
hundred deaths a the milestone they
reached a hundred death and I say yeah
they have 10 times smaller population
yeah we have a thousand times more
deaths I mean you know yeah um and so
when you hear all South Korea they're
having problems again oh they had to you
know they had five cases somewhere in
there coming um and you know my concern
is not just these deep red states you
know like Arizona and Florida but look
what's happening in California and I
think it's because California's never
saw what New Yorkers saw I mean they
never saw the hospital's overrun right
because we caught it early enough in
California the first state to really
take action that it worked - good and so
people didn't see the hospital's overrun
people didn't see you know doctors have
to make triage decisions as to who gets
the ventilator and who doesn't and so
there was this complacency that and this
kind of black and white thinking like
we're just back to business as the post
is still taking precautions particularly
for those who are elderly particularly
those with these underlying risk factors
who are still at great risk right and
once the protest began the floodgates
open it's very hard to put that back in
the bottle right although you know now
that were weeks out well thankfully we
did not see the uptick that was
suspected by many I mean we think it's
because of of being outdoors I'm so in
1918 a lot of the transmission was
actually driven by these war bonds
marches on where they got people
together during the pandemic to raise
money for World War one and was and and
that was implicated a lot of spread so
even outdoors but now with the current
virus whatever the transmission it
really does seem the high-risk is
enclosed indoor poorly ventilated
crowded spaces for extended periods of
time that's where these so-called super
spreader events are happening that's
where you can get you know sixty percent
of people walking out of a bar and we're
later coming down infected whereas
despite the crowded conditions outdoors
you have once you're outside you have
the ultimate ventilation one little air
current and you're you know any little
respiratory droplets or aerosol that
gets you know that you exploit with you
breathing if you're chanting even if
you're yelling even if you're hacking
because of teargas these are I mean
these are conditions billed for the bars
you you know with all you need is a
little breeze and we did not see that
kind of right thankfully it seems that
we're every week we're learning a little
bit more and we're having to figure out
you know how to dismiss what we thought
was previously correct you know we were
disinfecting all our groceries and we
don't do that anymore and I thought are
we supposed to be doing that should we
be doing that or am I just being lazy
you know wearing masks of course is a
given but I think it would be helpful to
just point people in the right direction
in terms of you know just kind of
piggybacking on what you just said what
are the most of
two things that we should be doing what
are some of the things that we're doing
that perhaps we don't need to I just
don't know where that demarcation line
is there's a lot and I'm trying to
educate myself and I'm still confused
you know I know that I need to wear
masks I've watched videos of of where
you can see how it impedes the
expectoration of your breath but you
know if somebody's smoking a cigarette
you know hundred yards away from me I
can smell it so if I'm smelling that
does that mean that if that person is
infected that I'm potentially breathing
that too like it's it's very confusing
even for somebody who's actively trying
to get to the best practices right so
right even the most conscientious among
us are still having difficulty
separating kind of the wheat from the
chaff and knowing what do we know what
we really don't know and so I think
early on when we really didn't know the
transmission characteristics this virus
no all past pandemics have been
influenza pandemics and we know so much
about influenza it was easy for us to
know okay we know exactly how it's
spread we know exactly how to clamp it
down but this is a new virus and so we
really didn't know the transmission
characteristics and so something like
the surface disinfection of anything
coming into the house I mean anything
early on that was a legitimate act
because we just didn't know how much it
so called for my transmission to
doorknobs and light switches and toilet
flushes and gas pump handles we didn't
know how much was contacting you know
then touching our mucous membranes eyes
nose mouth before disinfecting our hands
now we know that is that is not the
primary means of transmission and so and
now that we had enough time where people
have been isolated in home and their
only contact with the outside world wars
the delivered groceries and delivered
food and there we have not seen
validated cases um even among people
that aren't taking any special
precautions okay so now we can breathe a
sigh of relief and we can and we can
take in this information realize okay
now we we know what to prioritize in
life in terms of reducing our risk and
what's the priority distance distance
distance that's really I mean there's
this really overinflated reliance on
masks that give us a false sense of
security
remember that masks are not to protect
us the masks are to protect other people
from us right it reduces those
respiratory droplets that come out of
our mouths with conversational speech
are just normal exhalation and and the
thing about this virus as well as
influenza you may Kate come contagious
before you start showing symptoms and so
days after being exposed to this virus
you can feel perfectly fine look
perfectly for an MB exhaling virus with
every breath and that's why if you don't
know who's infected and who's not that's
where the social distancing coming and
without sufficient testing you don't
know who's infected there's nothing she
just have to try to keep everybody away
from everyone else that's what the
social distancing measures were
implemented for and still the most
important thing we can do to protect
ourselves is I mean it's like that's the
good news like you cannot get the virus
if the virus cannot get to you and how
do we get the virus from other people so
reducing as much as possible or contacts
outs of our outside of our household and
if we have to have contacts outside of
our household it's for a short time in
as well-ventilated area as possible
particularly for those that are
vulnerable or for those who come in
contact with those vulnerable and so and
so there's this gradations of risk
there's a riskiest behavior there's the
riskiest populations and then all the
way down to you know maintaining a sense
of social cohesion but I mean you
realize you know as bad as cup of 19 has
been right we still the grocery stores
are still being restocked we still have
electricity we still have clean drinking
water
um doctors are still showing up to work
you have a pandemic with something like
a 7 & 9 h5n1 when case fatality rates
like literally a flip of a coin whether
or not you die from this virus then you
could imagine how much worse this
situation could be that's why it's so
yeah it would be straight-up
apocalyptic if that was going on right
now and you hear stories like I just
read a story the other day about a super
spreader event a wedding in India and I
think 90 people contracted the virus as
a result of attending that event but
there isn't some situation in which
every
worker at Ralph's suddenly in the
hospital mm-hmm which is interesting
kind of around people all day they're
wearing masks but you know I haven't
heard of any grocery workers at least on
at scale contracting the disease so we
care these doors but I guess they're all
wearing masks so we're still trying to
understand what's behind the super
spreading event so some of them like
this this famous choral group where 80%
of those unlike God infected in one
choral singing session anything oh well
not only indoors in one room but they're
you know they're there they're there
they're spewing virus out into the air
and so that would that would that would
make sense that that would be and then
you look at the meatpacking plants where
it's so loud you have to talk really
loud shout into people's ear then
they're so packed tight um and it's and
it's chilly which actually may play a
role in enhancing my viral stability and
the prisons are now becoming hot spots
again that just makes sense and so we
can explain a lot of these but there may
be characteristics of certain people or
certain strains of the virus that do in
kind of whatever situation that would
have been in could you know lead to mass
infection and imagine being the bride
and groom of that right inviting people
I mean or any kind of function right I
mean we really need to think before we
have that you know before we bring over
people to the house party yeah yeah and
just we should think you know God what
if our what if we heard whatever some of
one of our dearest friends right or our
family so you know we just read this is
the Newton what Americans want what they
want when they won't know and this is
this is we're seeing a little evidence
of that we this is the wake-up call yes
I mean it's really and it's not going
away anytime soon all right I mean I
talk about in the book written months
ago that you know that there's no reason
we should expect that this should go
away in the summer the other quart of
irises don't they blah blah blah and
here it is continue to rage on during
their in the hot summer months and so
and so the only way to stop pandemic is
through herd immunity having a certain
portion of the populace
mewn to the virus an infection can only
burn through a population if there are
enough susceptible individuals for viral
sparks to jump for one person to the
next
immune individuals who can't get or
transmit the virus act as fire brakes to
slow the spread or like control rods and
in a nuclear reaction to break the
chains of transmission now ideally this
herd immunity is achieved through
massive vaccinations right vaccines are
way to to use like fire to fight fire
you use the virus to fight the virus by
generating the benefits of infection
immunity without generating the risks
with disease and death ah
not without a vaccine then herd
immunities only achieve the hard way
through mass infection hmm but looking
at the characteristics of the virus we
have now we suspect herd immunity will
be achieved when 60 or 70 percent of the
population is infected when there's that
many people who are immune this is
assuming that we have some kind of at
least short-term immunity one sixty or
seventy percent of the population is
unable to get or transmit this virus
then the 30 to 40 percent who are
completely susceptible are protected by
everybody else and the VAR stops right
pandemic ends
and so the goal particular if you're
older particularly if you're if you're
sick um any of these underlying risk
factors you want to end up in the third
and forty percent we're at the end of
all this the pandemic is over and you
never got infected
you never were at risk right that's the
goal and hopefully we were able to get
that through vaccines but you we need to
realize reality check vaccines
historically taken 11 years that's the
average and has a 94 percent failure
rate meaning 94 percent never made the
market um now that this is a totally
different situation we have literally a
hundred and fifty candidate vaccines in
the pipeline so the whole world is
jumping on this so we should certainly
see an accelerated timeline but you know
you have to test enough people to ensure
sufficient safety and so we should not
expect to have a war whole vaccine
the general population till 2nd - mm
second yeah it's a long way off and herd
immunity is a long way off short of that
what would have to happen I mean so
we're about five to eight percent 5de
percent of Americans have been affected
so far now I'm at now unfortunately some
of the some of the early data on
immunity it's possible that um immunity
to this virus may be short-lived
so we're seeing that a lot with
coronaviruses there's other
coronaviruses for which um you come back
months later I'm so with like common
cold coronaviruses forty five weeks so
four to five weeks of immunity and then
you're just as susceptible again so it's
possible we get into a flu vaccine kind
of suits in all right where you'd have
to get vaccinated every year to maintain
immunity to this virus but some of the
early data suggests that some of the
people that got infected early may now
I'm starting to become susceptible again
based on the level of have so-called
neutralizing antibodies in their blood
the ones that really target kind of the
the receptor mechanism of this virus we
have yet to test what's happening to
their t-cells is IC to memory immune
systems in the body the antibodies and
the t-cells both can retain memory of
infectious exposure in main to gave that
lasting immunity so far we've tested
antibodies and they've been
disappointing may only last weeks in
terms of infection so then herd immunity
is much more difficult to achieve but we
we have yet to really see what's
happening with these memory t-cells
maybe they will give us the and that's
what we saw with SARS SARS antibody
levels went down they had some memory
T's thankfully we eradicated SARS from
the planet and how could we get rid of
that deadly coronavirus
and we're having such problems with this
one because with that one you only
became infectious after you started
showing symptoms in fact peak
infectivity was ten days after you
started coughing
coffee for ten days later you're
spreading it ah put up fever monitors
and every boy's ear who started I mean
still with 8,000 people got infected and
killed about 10% killed about 800 people
but we could stop it we didn't know that
we could have a corona virus where we'd
have the
loo like infectivity during incubation
period infectious before show symptoms
and that's that's what that's why we're
in this situation all right right well
it would seem important to be able to
answer that question about whether we
can contract it again critic long that
is right for yes for vaccines for
everything so have it you know there was
this talk of having an immunity passport
right proving I have Randi I'm and of
course the concern if that gave you some
kind of perks you had better jobs or
whatever people would infect themselves
like I have like Quranic parties too and
then you could get the little immunity
path but if we really don't have lasting
immunity they don't last for a few
months um then what is what does it even
mean to have gotten the virus um if you
can get to get a few months later yeah
we've been doing antibody testing here
and with regularity people are
disappointed to find out that they
didn't have it everybody you know thinks
oh in February I had a you know I was
sick so I probably had it sniffles one
of these right um but and and it's
possible that having an asymptomatic
case like you test positive but you
never really or you had a mild case
symptoms you actually may even get less
immunity from that and it really may
take because it kind of passed under
your immune system radar and you just
said and that that your body was able to
squash it so quickly that your body
didn't have to mount much response at
all right and so it considers it such
kind of my alumni are gonna worry about
mounting this constant like right now
your your bone marrow is pumping out
anti chickenpox vaccine uh antibodies
right now and will for the rest of your
life if you had chicken pox is child's
and most everybody has and your body's
wasting lots of energy every single day
making chicken pox making v measles
making anti and it's a lot of generates
a lot and in fact immune cells expend
more energy than your heart cells which
are pumping every single day these are
huge they're literally buddy probably
got millions of antibodies every minute
it's just these little you know I mean
there but that's because that was our
one of our primary threats to our
existence on this planet historically
throughout evolution were the infectious
disease threat
because bacteria and viruses multiply so
much quicker than we do and so we had it
was this back and forth you know they'd
get a little better our immune systems
would you know catch up but they've got
a few billion year head start on us
uh-huh evolutionarily and so that's why
we use our brains to develop technology
to be able to squash it and vaccines are
the technology that allowed us to for
example eliminate smallpox from the
planet Earth literally hundreds of
millions of people used to die because
of a disease that is now gone from the
face of the earth septons from bio
warfare labs and and and you know with
1976 I think last case never phone
thanks to vaccines so anyone says you
know questions vaccines you know we we
there was probably the greatest public
health victory of all time was the
elimination of smallpox there is no
longer a disease and that was thanks to
vaccination and so we should we should
we should hope and pray we have a safe
and effective vaccine for this in the
future on on the subject of herd
immunity what do you make of Sweden's o
strategy well you can ask what they made
it it and they they now realize it was a
mistake and they have some of the
highest infection and death rates in in
Europe in fact around the world and so
they they but but but if we like we're
looking at that at a discrete point on
the timeline to three years from now if
we're still grappling with this in a in
a you know in a material way and they're
not you know I feel like you know are we
able to really evaluate the merits or
demerits of that strategy right now well
even even in the most infected so even
in Stockholm which I think has the
highest I'm a post infection brace they
were still minute twenty five percent
hmm so they're raging now and so they
are still fine now we're much farther
from a herd immunity situation but the
point is to keep the disease and to have
had low enough rate until we achieve
that until that on a level of firm unity
is achieved I mean that has to happen
kind of across the board unless you
completely closed off your borders like
they were able to do
very successfully in New Zealand so if
Trump called you up in the middle of
this podcast and said Gregor I'm get you
in the White House tell me what to do
what what you know if you're in charge
if you're sitting in Falchi situation
all right now what's the what's the
problem well first of all I said look
I'm in a rich role podcast wait until
we're done but when I have a moment
well it's really putting the experts
back in charge so I mean in any other
circumstance the CDC would have been
leading this charge I mean they've been
effectively silenced right um and the
same thing with I mean it was like this
is Rand Paul told told Falchi he was not
being optimistic and not for the muzzle
be I mean and and so when when we don't
have the experts in charge I mean this
is this is this is and this is not just
happened in the US I happen to a certain
extent in in Brazil in in in UK in a
number of places where they can't have
these kind of this kind of autocratic
response instead of listening to the two
experts who have been spent you know
their lives doing this and so there are
good sources of information I don't want
to put a plug in for the Center for
infectious disease research and policy
at the University of Minnesota
Michael osterholm has a weekly broadcast
um so it is one of the sanest voice has
been doing this work for 45 years I
remember when I was doing my work I'm in
this you know 20 years ago I mean he was
a leading you know leading the charge
way back then and was you know with HIV
on down the road and so it's people like
him and Falchi who have this is they've
spent their entire lives studying this
and so then to have pandemic
preparedness you know documents going
back when I was writing about this and
that and you know I was kind of late to
the game 14 years ago or so you know we
had I mean you know and but then we had
all this this you know these plans and
there's threw it out the window
we just didn't follow what we needed to
do and and part I mean it's very
difficult politically because if it
doesn't if you're not if it doesn't look
like you're overreacting
they you're not doing enough frankly
because we have oh it's the mathematics
of exponential spread during a pen
and now in retrospect we know oh when we
had one case we had 10,000 then we had
you know and so you're always late to
the game but it always looks like your
your your your you know you know Chicken
Little because uh there's only a few
cases you know what I mean you know
let's not write that's not you know the
impact of the economy is such and this
was a certainly a new virus I mean so
they're sure for early missteps there's
you know I you know very few places
around the world we're ahead of the
curve and the ones that were like Hong
Kong Singapore South Korea they had
recently suffered deadly coronavirus
outbreak so Cora South Korean 2015 had
this MERS outbreak some businessman came
back from from the Middle East and
started spreading and so they had this
testing and tracing public health
infrastructure intact the other country
suffered recent SARS outbreak right so
they had experienced this firsthand on
their soil their populace was ready they
were understood the risks and we're
ready to do whatever the experts were
told was necessary and said they were
able to jump ahead of the curve and you
get on this you start these social
distancing measures two days three days
early and you have this mathematical
modeling modeling suggesting you could
literally you know prevent millions of
cases in the long run if you know a week
earlier you did this a few days earlier
did this and that's because once it
spreads out of control it's very hard to
kind of put the put the lid back on
right I think that's what we're
experiencing now I mean the difference
being that there wasn't that kind of
popular will because the SARS and the
MERS like we knew about them but they
didn't really land on our shores in a
meaningful way right right in fact right
SARS never did so I'm sorry said Canada
never actually made it into the States
um
and so right we said we didn't have that
the history but we certainly had experts
who spent their whole lives preparing
for that situation in fact I was part of
these we there were you know these
governmental drills where we all got
together all we have these you know sick
chickens in Maryland and then what's
going to happen and what kind of
decisions we have to make and there was
all this kind of you know wartime game
planning for you know
you know departments and but you know it
just it's just not the window hmm and so
okay so early missteps right we you can
forgive around the world for countries
that have not had a recent history but
then right but now even even a few
months ago we were far enough in to
realize the situation we were in and had
to take it much more seriously yeah
there was this sense of what we just
have to lock down for you know ten days
or we just have to do this and it's
gonna be very temporary and like and all
the scientists are looking at each other
saying like what world do you live in
right but having said the messaging is
so confusing and it's not cohesive and
there is no sense that there's a real
plan so we kind of did that for a while
and then we kind of tiptoed out and then
suddenly we're protesting in the streets
and now we're like are well now we see
the spikes but are we gonna go back home
and nobody's really you know taking the
reins to articulate in a clear cohesive
manner what the steps are that we all
have to get on board with in order to
get on top of this so I just feel like
it's just gonna it's gonna run its
course and people are gonna do what
they're gonna do right now short of some
you know catastrophic spike that's going
to get people to wake up again cuz
getting them to go sequester in place
after the many months of you know what
we've been experiencing I think is gonna
be very difficult yeah yeah but I mean
that cement but that's if you can the
fewer people you come in contact with
supporting on time outs I mean and the
farther you can be away in the more
event I mean that's just you know now
having said that if you are under the
age 50 none of these comorbid conditions
but the chances of you dying from this
virus one in a thousand right I mean we
are talking about a in the scheme of
things a wimpy viruses are category too
bad dammit um ah but you know we should
all be you know well informed as to
what's risky what's not risky what can
we do to reduce our risks should we have
to come at act act and then the you know
you know it's great well setting aside
the comorbidity factors you know if
you're not obese have high blood
pressure heart disease etc if you're not
in a nursing home you are in a much
better position to combat this should
you come into contact with it but we've
all heard the stories of young fit
people who have either perished or
gotten so tremendously ill that they're
having trouble recovering so let's talk
a little bit about this narrative that
it's just like the flu or it's just a
little bit more serious than the flu
like what is the difference between the
flu like as we kind of understand it as
Americans versus the experience of
contracting this disease and what
happens to your body when you have it
yeah so I mean so for those in the
public health community even saying
something is as bad as the flu as a way
to minimize it doesn't it for infectious
disease folks flu is a scourge that
kills tens of thousands Americans every
you know every year and and you know
unfortunately the annual backs flu
vaccine is not very effective between 30
to 50 percent decreased risk which hey
better nothing but you know we're gonna
able to really put a put a lid on this
virus come surging back every year and
it's been the leading cause of death
that's where I have a chapter on it and
how not to die because one of the
leading causes of death ma you know this
low respiratory tract infections or no
pneumonia primarily caused by influenza
and so but this is but a bad flu year
has a point one a case fatality rate one
a thousand people getting it um whereas
for a cup of 19 we're looking at point
four now so at least four times worse
and of course it depends on on what age
group you fall in but that's kind of all
across the board unfortunately here in
the United States even without taking
obesity into account over age 50 most
Americans actually have some comorbid
condition I think their high blood
pressure or heart disease or diabetes
and so yeah and so you know all these
these lifestyle medicine pushes to
enhance you know to to increase our
resistance against chronic disease
sometime for in the future now is
helping us right right now
and so you know this message to you know
better take care of ourselves some
family has never been more kind of there
isn't enough discussion about what we
can do to buttress our immunity or you
know make sure that our immune response
is intact and healthy and a corollary to
that is also I think there's this idea
that we want our immune system to be as
robust as possible but is it possible
that it can become too robust yeah
that's the irony here so we have amazing
studies showing the simple foods can
boost one's immune function so I have
videos nutrition facts the door talking
about randomized double-blind
placebo-controlled trials showing that
for example broccoli sprouts can reduce
viral loads for influenza decrease virus
induced inflammation boost antiviral
natural killer cell activity but this
isn't the flu unlike other common
viruses corona viruses do not have not
been shown to cause more severe disease
in immunocompromised people those with
HIV those are on chemotherapy or
anything they're vulnerable to other
infections not to coronavirus infections
including kovat 19:08 a second how does
that make any sense because it's your
own immune system that's the primary
driver of lung damage during infection
during the second week of infections
during the infection the second week of
symptomatic and infection with Cova 19
the virus can trigger what's called a
cytokine storm which is like an
autoimmune reaction I'm where your body
ovary acts and in attacking the virus in
your attacking virus your lungs get
caught in the crossfire and in you know
burning down the village in order to
save it we may not make it through that
process so while I'm certainly in favor
of common you know common sense
generalized
you know advice to stay healthy such as
sufficient sleep and staying active and
reducing stress staying connected I'll
be a you know remotely with friends and
families eating healthy but I would not
you know take a specific sub go out of
your way to take a specific supplement
or dismissive
food to boost some element of your
immune system until we know more hmm
about this virus because potentially we
could be doing more harm when we're
well-intentioned and trying to do good
I've been hammering the broccoli sprouts
and also vitamin D we're hearing a lot
about vitamin D so what are your
thoughts on that so so there are a
number of of vitamins and minerals that
are critical for optimal immune function
vitamin D is one of them
vitamin C zinc selenium but there's no
evidence to suggest that super enormo
levels have any benefit so you need
sufficient for functioning immune system
so all the studies that show for example
zinc improves heart outcomes for disease
so you give zinc to children with
pneumonia significantly decrease
mortality rates randomized
placebo-controlled trials zinc verses
sugar pills to children with pneumonia
those given the zinc significantly less
likely to die but where is every single
one of these studies been done
sub-saharan Africa Ecuador places where
there is micronutrient deficiencies so
if you find a deficient population not
getting enough zinc giving them zinc can
get bring them up to mute but if you
have someone with functioning immune
system um with adding zinc do anybody do
any good if you're if you're having
enough if you have enough vitamin C have
enough slate desert there's no evidence
that having higher levels so having said
that vitamin D deficiency is rampant is
rampant even in you know the the
problems that's shining example of this
is there is a study of skateboarding
teens in Hawaii right and you just
imagine them shirtless all day right and
they even they had these high rates why
is that um well it's because we evolved
running around naked in Equatorial
Africa um being baked in the Sun all day
long and so if you want to know what
normal vitamin D levels are you measure
people who work outside all day long I
mean that's what that's kind of a
natural level of vitamin D and so we
were never meant to have these winters
and inside and wear clothes and all
these things that cut down on the
natural vitamin D production and so for
people that don't get sufficient midday
sir
particularly those with darker skins
particularly were older particularly
those with more body fat a may need to
supplement with vitamin D and so I would
recommend 2,000 and ashy units a day for
those who get insufficient some that's
what I do because I'm inside all day I
got my D levels tested once before I
supplemented and I had the D levels of
an institutionalized elder like these
people who are like nursing homes and
literally never got outside that was me
in front of my laptop or mr. nutrition I
just never got I got work to do I got a
book to write what do you mean
and so right so in fact 2000 was enough
for me so 2,000 would get most people
from the general level up to optimal
right um but for me who got no son I had
more so a couple questions on that it's
not about mega dosing it's about just
making sure that you're not deficient
but I think it's probably safe to
presume that there's a good chance you
are deficient because so many people are
short of getting a blood test to
determine that if you are depleted or
deficient how long does it take to
restore you know that balance is that
happen quickly or is it a fact so
rapidly that you can actually randomize
people with infection to vitamin D while
they have the infection and improve
disease outcomes um and so that's good
you increase their levels Walt lay on
the wall I mean so literally within the
days your immune systems like come on
people we need some vitamin D right now
right and so right so so very rapidly
were you able to improve and the same
thing with these think stones right they
gave them to kids not before they got
infected to see how they if they got
infected how they do literally they were
already sick gave them zinc and then a
few days later they were live or dead
whether or not they could sing so
another problem with zinc is he there
isn't even a blood test so you couldn't
get tested for xing sufficiency if you
want to but if you are so but if you
were eating a nutrient-rich diet right
which is well where all vitamins and
minerals come from with only two
exceptions it's just from the ground and
so you know you know and
and bye-bye eating by eating them
implants ah ma I mean that's where the
car that's where we should get um I
dealing with the two exceptions of
vitamin D the sunshine vitamin vitamin
b12 which made by microorganisms which
blanket the earth but we now chlorinate
our water supply don't don't get a lot
of b12 in our water don't get a lot of
cholera either that's a good thing we
have a nice sanitary system but again
because the way we lived in a modern
world like with vitamin D because we
live in a modern world we have to yeah
sure we get a regular liable source of
vitamin b12 what other what other foods
should we be mindful of making sure that
we're getting that our nutrient rich and
the way that we want our needed given oh
but so fruits vegetables legumes the
same litany right beans lentils
chickpeas split peas whole grains nuts
the seeds herbs and spices mushrooms
real food grows out of the ground feels
not factories a nice thing you know it's
not its experience the basic stuff right
this is where I get tired of talking
about this uh oh my god well I mean it's
but it's even more relevant now and if
and if people are gonna start eating
healthy now because they don't want to
die from the virus and and my my secret
plan is for them not to get breast
cancer in ten years and I don't get died
of a heart attack look whatever it takes
for them right I would appeal the vanity
tell people helps with acne I mean
anything to get people to eat healthy
because I know it's gonna save their
lives later on and so maybe this will
have the side benefit of starting some
healthy habits they're gonna stick with
them and thanks to the pandemic are not
going to you know croak in ten years
right stroke
what about viral load we hear a lot
about viral load right you you touched
on it a little bit ago that that you
know we want to avoid these you know
endure kind of hotspot settings where
we're in close proximity to each other
but I'm not sure I fully understand the
like the idea is that you could
potentially come into contact with the
virus but if it's in a passing way if
it's not you know in one of those
cloistered kind of settings that perhaps
you're not going to contract the disease
that's your smoker fifty foot away right
we have this sense that one one viral
particle we get exposed to the virus and
all sudden we get infected
and you must realize that even if
someone with active tuberculosis coughs
in
your face the chances of you getting
tuberculosis like one two hundred really
because you have an immune system now if
you have HIV or it's some yeah impaired
that's what your immune system is for we
we were built to fight off invaders
right and so only under certain
circumstances when we have sufficient
it's called the viral load when there's
sufficient so you pick a pathogen and
there's an average viral load for coli
bacteria one e.coli bacteria the odds
that that's going to trigger infection
even though they multiply like crazy or
one Salmonella no it's it's you need you
need a sufficient dose that's why um
like pasteurization that's not about
sterilizing milk cooking it's not about
sterilizing the meat I mean it's about
reducing the the number of infections
sold that is below the infectious load
and so when it comes to respiratory
pathogen it's not that you you have to
prevent yourself from breathing in one
particle ads you have to reach a
sufficient number of infectious
particles and whether that's a thousand
whether that's ten thousand we
unfortunately don't know yet with kovat
19 but we do know it for other
respiratory pathogens and you can I mean
you could dose it out and how do you do
it well they do the stage of the
influence with a young healthy people
that are really low likelihood of
suffering and they little drip it in
their nose so they drip a thousand of
the nose and see how many percentage of
100 people drip two thousand and their
nose they drip ten thousand right and
you can find out exactly how much so we
don't have that data yet because we have
a new virus but we always know that I
mean otherwise the the disease was
spread even more happen than this so it
is on intensity of exposure and at plus
duration of exposure so everyone's
freaked out about elevators right but
how long are you in that elevator right
it's so it's if you have someone in your
home who is infected and you have a
studio apartment and they're not in
their own room and they're hacking away
and they yes they have us they have a
cloth face covering and they're we're
trying to wipe down all the doorknobs
and we have those windows open and the
exhaust fan on the stove going and in
the bathroom going you have an air
purifier and like you were trying to do
the best to maintain ventilation you're
living with that virus for
long period of time in and and that that
puts you in extremely high risk is these
crowded settings um and in fact they do
they now we have these beautiful studies
where you know we've traced everyone
back to one of these restaurant events
and use and they have the the little map
of all the tables where all the people
are the tables and here is the index
case and everybody over here got it no
one even sitting next to them over here
got it why because the airflow is going
this way right here's the air vent
here's the air bed everybody got it this
way and the person sitting three feet
away on the other hand didn't get it is
because these little tiny these are like
little dust motes that you see when the
sun's rays come in they just kind of
float around but one little teeny breath
we just you know blow them to one end of
the room or the other hmm um and so it's
butts just being in this cloud of little
dust motes breathe in one breathe in two
three than three and it's and so when
you look at these contact tracing apps
and contact tracing protocols
they're asking who have you been close
to that's the intensity under six feet
and for more than fifteen minutes we've
been close to they so the so is less
than a minute that is that random or is
that calculated is there a scientific
basis without fifteen minutes okay
window not scientific basis for Cova
nineteen because we don't know right we
don't know the parameters yet but so
that's based on other respiratory
pathogens so basically all this modeling
has to do we have other respiratory
passage we have common cold viruses we
have influenza viruses and so we have
other data from viruses we think
transmitted very similarly based on the
data we have so far so based on that you
know we're not even going to call on the
phone someone you spoke with directly
face-to-face for ten minutes two days
ago and now you're in the hospital there
that they aren't even so that likelihood
that they're a minute threshold but so
fifty minutes and they had to be close
so a fifteen minutes you spent all hours
but you were outside on the porch with
someone who's eight feet away from you
not even go call em hmm
then what about well look we're seeing a
clampdown now on indoor dining a lot of
restaurants and you know in California
at least they're closing some of open
they're closing back down
there's
you know every state is different but
airplanes seem like a bad idea
recycle there we're seeing these
Airlines announced that you know they're
not going to restrict their seating you
just were on a plane I mean that just
seems like the worst idea so there's uh
there's it's safer than being in a
similarly confined space just because of
the they actually HEPA filtered through
the air system so you actually should
have those that you can imagine being in
a plane not wanting that recycled air in
your face no that's exactly what you
want your face you should open all three
of those nozzles if you're not sitting
next someone point them all towards you
you have this wave of air pushing past
your nose for someone someone walks
there's a few does that air cause that
air recycle those completely recycle so
somebody in the back is coughing and it
kids through through HEPA filter which
is not a perfect filter but it does
filter out the majority of the type of
droplets we think are carrying this
virus and so you have this semi purified
air blow fishing everything else of
wooshing everything else away now that
is not a I would not consider that a low
risk scenario um but look when you gonna
be on the rich roll podcast you take you
run the cost-benefit you showed up man I
appreciate that taking that risk what
about what about masks okay so you go
out in the world you see all variety of
masks from the guy with a who's got the
bandana around his neck covering his
mouth but not his nose you've got cloth
masks like this you got the n95 like how
important is it to have a high quality
mask i what should we be thinking about
when we're making that decision about
what kind of mask so the only mask
actually designed to protect the user
the wearer are these n95 masks which
were specifically designed for that
purpose they filter their they filtered
the air coming in hmm and so that is
what's being recommended for medic
personnel and but those that's not
something you just you know that it has
to be something has to be fitted to your
face actually go through a fitting
process in the hospital to make sure you
have the right size for your face you
can't even have a day of beard growth so
everybody with any facial hair covering
that that area is completely I mean that
it breaks the seal this is a meant to be
an airtight seal and the material has
this electrostatic charge that traps
these microscopic little floating
particles I'm such that you can wear it
with just someone coughing active TB
germs um and and been very effective for
copa90 now of course you can infect
yourself taking it on and off and you
know you can you can you there can be an
inadequate seal for whatever reason um
you really shouldn't use it's meant to
be disposable now we don't have enough
even for medical professionals and some
that we have to reuse the mass and we
don't have enough data to show how many
times you can reuse it now saga you can
get and what kind of protection I'm
still existing can you reuse it after
you decontaminate it on and on and
that's why so no one is recommending n95
masks for the public not because they
don't work but because we don't have
enough to go around now that's not our
fault right that is a failure of the
national stockpile we should have had n
95s for for for all medical
professionals as have other countries
and in fact other countries have
provided you know surgical masks for
their entire populace for free
and so now surgical masks are meant to
protect others from the wear so that's
why surgeons wear them so they're not
breathing germs into an open surgical
wound that's at least the theory
although there's only been two
randomized controlled trials and there's
actually no drop in infectious raids
during surgery surgeons wearing masks
versus not wearing that I don't want so
even surgical masks are of questionable
utility for cutting down on disease
transmission and the cloth face
coverings there's no data to suggest
that they're useful certainly during
1918 they were found not to be
successful the the benefit so the my
concerns is false insecurity mm-hmm
the critical factor of getting affected
is distance distance distance lightens
the time and distance and so if you but
if you feel invulnerable or you feel
lower risk because you have that mask on
and you would go places you would not
normally go or you would stay longer or
be closer to people than you normally
would
that's how a mask could actually
increase your risk of rise all indirect
ways it could decrease risk of infection
the people really need to be using like
the surgical masks at the cloth face
hurting or people are actively hacking
coughing actively symptomatic there I
mean they are spewing out virus like
crazy they really need to be wearing
masks if you go outside no one's wearing
a mask and you know you're infected and
you have a fever and you're coughing but
you need to know the drugstore you live
alone you need to go outside and no one
else is wearing a mask the social cost
but no one you know of putting on a mask
and flagging I'm infected um you can
imagine how people might not do that
whereas if by law or by decree or by
social contract everyone's wearing a
mask you are more likely being
symptomatic to wear a mask and protect
others um and so that's a way how masks
could really help even if it doesn't
necessarily cut much down on the
asymptomatic transmission which is what
we're hoping we're hoping that those
tiny little respiratory droplets that we
spew out of her mouth during normal
conversational speak we're gonna trap
some of those with a cloth face covering
do we have data showing that's the case
we do not and so when the CDC came out
and said we changed our minds a base on
the new data or based on the latest
science we are we are going to recommend
everyone wear cloth face coverings and
you say well you go to the CDC website
what's this new science they cite the
national national institute of medicine
um and you go there you say what did
they do and they came out said master
probably a good idea based on what date
but they're very clear say we have no
data showing that they actually work
theoretically it could cut down on some
of this transmission again not not
helping the wearer but helping other
people from the wear
if they're infected not even knowing it
but um but this but my biggest concern
false sense of security
I have something called my face so I can
go to the grocery store twice as many
times as I did before and I don't have
to exactly stay as far away from other
people as I you know that's how masks
could be part yeah I think of it much
like it's basically a a tool for social
distancing like it's sort of buying you
a foot or two right like instead of
making sure that I'm you know six feet
apart maybe I can be five feet apart but
it's not doing anything more than that
is that or or you could imagine it
working even better the presence of
masks reminding people you're during a
pandemic it looks weird walking around
like cashiers people are on the street
it's amazing how quickly we normalized
to it not I don't think now I just yeah
I think of it's normal right I mean it's
funny when you look at these 19 so I was
at the National Archives when I was
writing the book and doing talks about
it and going through and seeing all that
you know major baseball you know back in
the 1918 everyone's wearing masks and
the spectators it just looks so weird to
have people with you know billy clubs
and mass son but now right it's amazing
how quickly but if it reminds you first
sample wearing wearing gloves on your
hands
and the reason say was no point in
wearing gloves on your hands in public
because you can just as easily infect
you know rub your eye with your gloves
as with your hands and so you have to
wash your hands gloved or not but if
having bright pink gloves on your hands
well as you go up yeah you know I mean
if that reminds you and you just look
down and it feels weird and it's awkward
and you're everyone's looking at you
because you got breaking it if that
keeps you mindful of the position of
your hands that could be a good thing
that could cut down on rates of it
you're just because you're not you know
it's not business as usual if masks make
it not business as usual I mean it's
just a little you know it's constant
reminder oh maybe I should be a little
more careful in this situation or not go
somewhere then that could help testing
testing testing we need more testing
testing is the way that we're gonna get
on top of this when should we get tested
what kind of test should we take there's
all kinds of tests out there
what are these tests telling us about
how we're responding to this problem
right like I think like oh testing
testing testing I've gotten in a my bi
test a couple times I've been negative I
haven't had the full swab test you know
do you wait until you're symptomatic
like when is the appropriate time to
explore that and I don't go yes so
testing testing testing only makes sense
if it depends what you're going to do
with those results and so testing is
critical to know what's happening with
the virus and without that information
then you're flying blind so you want to
know if some kind of stay at home mortar
actually helped or not you want to know
be able to trade with these protests
would that lead to a big spike or not
it's still so early on we're gathering
data regarding gathering intel on our
enemy
and so without testing we're completely
flying blind and we just don't know how
far are we away from a herd immunity
what's helping what's not helping what
are those super spreader events how can
we avoid those what kind of you know
occupations what kind of restaurants are
good bad you know we don't know that if
we don't have it sufficient tests and so
we have been and so the countries that
have done the best I'm so South Korea
for example they were ramping up to test
literally within 10 days and thousands
of tests a day we weren't testing at all
at that point and it's interesting they
actually had that we had our first cases
on the same day South Korea in the US
and you look at our curves I mean it's
completely vanquished it and we're still
raging on so what are you gonna do with
that testing and so so basic what's
called SERO prevalence testing you just
want to know you want to do random
sampling um as part of an experimental
set up to in various areas of the
country on a consistent basis to know
what's happening with the virus where
and so we can gauge that against our
hospital capacity
how many been relators we have in that
county how many you know how many ICU
beds and then we can make these
decisions do we open do we close or
window should we be pumping the brakes
on this kind of social assisting
obviously we won't want is
little as possible we want to be able to
have as much freedom of movement and
continue the you know vitality the
country's much as possible until unless
we're gonna start running out of beds
right until I mean that's the whole
point of flattening the curve you're not
necessarily reducing the number of
people that are gon die we're gonna get
sick you're spreading them out
you're just we know this many people are
gonna die but if they all die but if
they all come in the hospital this week
then more gonna die then if they come
out over the next ten weeks now it's
possible if we slow it to the extent
that we hit a vaccine aha that's the
game changer so we can slow things down
enough then then that slowing flattening
the curve strategy then does indeed
result in fewer deaths overall because
ah then we finally have a method to stop
the virus without getting people
infected and so so they're there there's
a there certainly in place for testing
in terms of individual testing right now
there isn't sufficient tests available
and this goes back to having enough
swabs enough reagents on it and now
we're dealing with this with a future
vaccine we don't enough glass vials in
the world to even put the vaccines in so
then then if you're gonna use one if
you're gonna stick needles into one vial
instead of having single-use files and
you have to add preservatives adds
another safety issue and I mean it I
mean so basic and of course public
health community has been shouting about
this forever I have this in my book
fourteen years ago the supply chains are
not sufficient to have enough mass to
have enough PPE to have enough of the
basics we need so that's we're running
into the testing and so it's like mass
what are the best mass Oh within ninety
five so I'll shoot at should everyone
have an n95 no we can't because we need
them for the frontline workers even even
surgical mass which are better than
cloth mass we're telling people not to
use those because we don't have enough
for the medical workers and so that's
right you know DIY making it home with a
with a sweatshirt even though we don't
have data showing that's necessarily I'm
as effective as people think it is um
it's so Sammy was testing what we like
we want weekly testing for everyone in
the country right then then we can rub
but we don't have that capacity so who
should get tested
um it is people that are coming in
contact with vulnerable individuals that
is the highest so people working in a
nursing home we want that staff tested
um because one case in that just can
explode right right um
so people in you know prisons that
haven't already been overrun like San
Quentin um I you know it's kind of at
that point it's almost too late what
we're seeing in some of these but it's
those kind of high risks in ours these
are the people we want regularly tested
so we could pull them out of circulation
X it's ironic actually goes back to the
porn industry and HIV that's how the
porn industry is work right here was a
deadly virus and there was yet there was
an industry where you had to continually
put yourself at risk to be an Ender so
what do they do
they instituted a mandatory testing I
forget exactly how quick how frequently
need to get tests and you could not work
unless you come back with a negative
test and you would be out of work they'd
figure it out the interval right like it
was every two weeks or they had whatever
was right and so they could they could
constantly and so that's what we need
and so that's we should let the porn
industry that they they're always out
front these technological breakthroughs
that the whole concept of testing
tracing actually came from the STD world
I mean that's what you know you have a
case of gonorrhea huh we need to find
everyone you slept with recently and we
need an honest they call them on the
phone and say someone you've been with
recently had gonorrhea you need to go
get tested so you don't then spread it
to everybody else that's the concept of
content of testing tracing it's so much
more difficult now with this respiratory
virus because it's spread so much
quicker and so you can imagine how many
people have you you know had this kind
of 15-minute window and in close
proximity in the last and you're like
well I just went to this wedding right
and then all of a sudden you can imagine
how olson one wedding just makes this
explosive number of contacts whereas if
you have been trying to distance as much
as possible as far as possible from as
many people as possible
it's like who've been with off there's
just been one you know one or two we
could contact those people think again
we can imagine how you can right but
yeah even I mean we need a hundred
thousand workers
and it's and the problem is and then you
call people up and you say someone
you've come in contact with in the next
few day in the last few days has tested
positive so you should quarantine for 14
days who wants to get that phone call
right okay you get that phone call what
are you gonna do with that information
is not no fault of your own you're going
on your own business someone tells you
and now you've got to lose to two weeks
of work well obviously you should be
compensated for those two weeks of work
and there's ways you can make it easier
but you can imagine even in the best
case scenario where it all works we're
all testing people you can still imagine
how difficult this to kind of put the
rabbit back in that what about some of
these nonvaccine drug protocols that
we're hearing about I just read that the
USA acquired the entire stock of REM des
aveer what's going on yeah all of this
yeah well I mean that's yeah I mean
that's that's that's the US health care
system right so yeah so this company
comes out of this drug has no drug
cocktail to date that in pervious
studies actually shown to decrease
mortality I mean so that's the best
thing I mean that that should be the
standard I mean um yeah so what REM
disappear has shown to do is decrease
the number of days in the hospital so
number days that you're sick and look if
you're sick with this virus sure give me
some of that cuts a couple days but does
it actually help people live through
this fire that that's the that should
becomes a treat like one aspect like
like alleviate some of the symptoms of
the disease as we doing but it's um it
seems to be slowing the virus down such
that your immune system can get a can
get a can get a-- i say you know and
similarly there's a there's a drug
called oseltamivir or Tamiflu for
influenza just very similar thing does
not actually decrease mortality from
influenza but may save a day or two off
of hospitalization of a severe course
certainly still give the drug but
whether or not the government should be
spending bill giving billions of dollars
to big pharma to buy these drugs so
they're selling these the remm disappear
for $3,000 a course I mean so and but if
it's not actually showing to saving
lives couldn't that 1.5 billion dollars
be spread in a way where we could you
know and so there's there's you know I
mean we just need to I mean
it's possible that before vaccine we
will have an effective treatment by
effective treatment we actually reduces
the risk of death we do not have that
yet we do have a decreasing number of
the even though we have an increasing
number of cases in the u.s. deaths have
gone down and flattened and largely
that's because younger people are
becoming affected now as soon as the
kind of relaxation so just think people
getting in bars and younger populations
are getting so the cases are scouring
but mortality is still staying
relatively low and though in large part
that's younger younger population is
getting affected what are some of the
wrongheaded kind of ideas that you see
percolating around like in the new cycle
you read oh you know we should do this
we should do that or and you just think
why you know this is not right like all
we need to do is this like I'm trying to
give people you know just some really
tacit advice that yeah I mean it
alleviates some of the confusion I mean
look in the nutrition space we know of
just a crazy ideological frenzy by which
people attached on to crazy ideas right
and defend them at all cost and the
confirmation bias but I have never seen
the kind of crazy that I've seen in
response to so now I have a whole series
of cover 19 videos I'm gonna switch the
research team to be working on on so we
have like serious 17 videos or something
and the responses now I put up a video
saying broccolis good i get the trolls
come out i mean that you know it does
not take much but but it's not a whole
new level now cuz you hit up you hit a
nerve with it right so i am a china
operative one moment and you know
whatever yeah yeah the the bill gates 5g
you know soros axis and and that and and
i think a lot of that comes from just
this terrible crisis communication at
the highest level I mean yeah I mean you
never to weaponize misinformation and
create division because this is
something that should not be politicized
and it's been unbelievably politicized
to a level that I think surprises every
I mean that's kind of a consistent
message so not much surprise the public
health community who the whole time
could write just a big carry a big I
told you so sign all day long every day
but that's something that really has
surprise and look there's always been
scapegoating for so you know the you
know the so-called Spanish flu of 1918
one reason called the Spanish flu was
because that was a neutral country and
so it was the only one that didn't have
censoring the news and so everyone out
the US like we don't have any flow you
know the Germans we don't have any flow
so them and it just got out of course in
Spain they called the French flow and
you know I mean and there's always
scapegoating of Jews during during you
know horrible epidemics there's always
been this kind of nasty something about
crises like this they kind of bring out
the worst in people as well as the best
of people but yeah but this this is
certainly at a level under and so that
just makes it even more important to get
information from you know decent sources
and I think we have this there's this
like well look you do your research I'll
do my research kind of thing like like
like as if like what exactly is your
research like you do your google is that
guy in his mom's basement to that guy
who spent his entire life studying so
this really shows the you know look I'm
I'm I I'm as opposed to as anyone this
kind of i-told-you-so
because I'm an authority I mean we've
seen where that has gotten us in trouble
but we should when someone says I'm an
authority you say show me your sources
like you weren't born with this
information how did you come across this
and and argue to me why this really is
the best and any expert worth their salt
should be able to say this is how I
arrived that here's the data here's the
science that shows that this is the
right course of action and but I mean
that should be that for whether you're
talking about nutrition whether to show
me the day where did you get this from
did you get it from your tinfoil hat
friend someone told you at the gym or
you know some check out a magazine
telling you this or did it actually have
some basis I mean if
any decision to be made based on science
based on the best available balance of
evidence it's something that affects the
health and well-being of yourself and
your family I mean that I mean that
should have a different bar of evidence
than an Amazon review for a new toaster
like I mean that's like the in that case
opinions of total strangers could be
useful for you oh you liked it because
oh okay thank you
right but we've gotten to this culture
of just like Oh random strangers have
ideas that are useful to me and then and
and somehow translate that and well yeah
we've we've arrived at this moment where
for whatever reason we've developed this
profound distrust of experts and that's
highly problematic in terms of seeing
our way forward as a society not just
experts in science but experts across
the board and you know a wide variety of
disciplines in their defense in the in
the defense of that is experts have done
a terrible job I mean so the Corporal
this is a [ __ ] show so you're giving
people plenty of reason to distrust the
right and historically I mean it was
there was the the tobacco industry that
weaponized first weaponized science and
it is the tobacco industry textbook that
has been used by every corporate entity
from then on we're talking about the
sugar industry weather type it's all
about they realize that policy is being
made but based on the science and so you
you control the science you control the
mess and so there was the backhoe
Research Institute they funded millions
of dollars paid off the AMA and so when
the AMA says smoking moderation is good
for you on balance not just neutral but
actually smoking is good for you most
doctors smoke so and now we say trust
the experts right Robin
you understand why yeah wait a second
the experts are saying that coca-cola
was good for me and that's because of
this corporate takeover over science
evidence-based medicine etc etc and so
there is good reason to be skeptical
when these decisions are made where
there's industry stakes by the billions
so something like should we get
mammograms okay that should seem like a
simple question of the science when
there's a billion dollar industry then
you need to you need to
not just take the experts word for it
but really dig into the signs right if
it's a question where there really is no
you know climate change when there's a
billion dollar industry on one side of
the issue
you always have to question until you
see what the best available balance of
evidence is and so the industry so you
can see how that that skepticism a big
pharma completely based in I mean I'm so
in fact the Tamiflu Fiasco who stands to
benefit in 2006
in my book on pending preparedness and
Preppers Bay way back then I talked
about the wonders of this drug Tamiflu
and how you should you know talk to your
doctor about getting you a prescription
of of this drug because there were 11
randomized control trials that showed
that a significantly decreased mortality
and morbidity from it saved lives from
the flu and and so the science in the
peer-reviewed literature was absolutely
dead unclear Roche one of the biggest
drug companies in the in the world had
they of course funded them all 11
studies but that's what drug companies
do kind of the only industry we put in
charge with their own self-regulation
but I mean but this wasn't some
fly-by-night company this is you know
company's been around okay and so then
so here I am writing the update right
for how to survive a pandemic so I'm
looking at template chapters I what's
what's been happening daily flu lately
right in 2009 with swine flu the group
of scientists Cochrane Collaboration
kind of the gold standard evidence-based
medicine well let's review what's
happening in Tamiflu because with swine
flu there were the government's were
making billions of dollars of purchases
of this drug for their national
stockpiles and some some pediatrician in
Japan said she said oh there's these 11
trials can we see the data please I went
to broach and said let's see the date of
the levant rose if you say there's lemon
trials I'll show that reduce and Bruce
refuses to give him the data hmm it's
like whoa wait a second now at the time
way back when it was still early we just
believed
I'm okay but now when they were making
big purses okay
and they knew every moment they could
delay recently releasing the data they
could get billions more in sales every
year they really billions more in sales
and it took some years and so it was
only I think till 2014 until they find
they were forced from national pressure
international pressures at scientific
community to release the data and guess
what it showed the opposite zero benefit
in terms of mortality but they had made
this calculus they were gonna bring in
so many billions of dollars that they
were going to just flat-out lie to the
governments of the world and say they
had this pandemic this drug that's gonna
save people from pandemic flu and just
raped in bed and they knew it was based
on a total lie but and it was this one
little pediatricians like we'd you see
the data just like and that's what
started it all we finally know it was
all it was a sham and it works just like
this REM does a barrage it shortens the
period but it doesn't actually result
immoral in live saved and so now it's
referred to as the Tamiflu flu Fiasco
that was modern-day big pharma pandemic
drug screwing the populace screwing tax
payers screwing government's the world
over and so you say I don't believe big
farm I'm skeptical about vaccines that's
a legitimate right
that's a legitimate place to be coming
from right we want the skepticism but
that skepticism shouldn't be I'm not
gonna let Bill Gates you know yeah I
have whatever Bill Gates is doing but I
it should be he makes it hard I want to
know the data trust I want to see so you
write your about you you heard par dr.
Greger are mired in the data the average
person is scrolling through their
Twitter feed just trying to make sense
of the world right you mentioned
osterholm yeah like who are the people
that we can you know safely pay
attention to and feel confident that
we're getting the right message who are
those people in science and who are
those people in the media who are
delivering this information like who is
the measured person where we can turn on
the television and not have to be you
know cocking our head every time they
say something and just
have some level of confidence that we're
getting the truth yeah so there's
actually been a number of journalists
that have been really stellar when it
comes to this and so statin news is
probably the source so that's the source
I could so statins so this is stat news
news is kind of a medical news source
that has prided itself on having a
really evidence-based balanced analysis
so they've probably been the done the
best work not saying everything they've
put out is right on the message but
they've really done some of the best
reporting to date and and in terms of
scientific entities CID wrap Center for
infectious disease research and policy
at the University of Minnesota Johns
Hopkins School of Public Health
um as a website puts out some excellent
information um ah and so in this way so
you don't have to um even me look even
ah
we're so right now there are 800
articles in the peer-reviewed scientific
literature coming out every day 800
every day and that's not talking about
preprints all the stuff in the pipeline
just being published every day so even I
can't stay on top of that and so even I
have to rely on on this kind of
collective group effort of let's all go
through these 800 pages every day papers
every day and really pick out what's
gonna be a kind of changing in terms of
practicality what is this new
information um that's reliable and
that's where these these these important
you know expert sources and and the CDC
despite some flubs early on with testing
and despite the the kind of wishy-washy
mask recommendation has has put out some
consistent good is there anybody just in
mainstream media like I feel like Sanjay
Gupta has been pretty measured and how
he's communicating around this I mean I
don't you know who do you think is yes
I've not been following the
instream who's in the mainstream in this
journal right my journals and in this
and the scientists and so right
unfortunately now there are people with
PhDs and MDS of into the name and they
think all of a sudden that they're
infectious disease experts or or you
know aerosol experts or you know
occupational safety I mean there are
people who spend their whole lives
figure out transmission of disease and
just because you have an MD does mean
you're an expert in this at all then
just keep spouting nonsense about all
sorts of things and put out mathematical
models that you know they're computer
scientists and they suggest that they're
modeling it says do this as opposed to
this where they really don't have
expertise in that particular area so
even you know just trust the experts
yeah I mean that's not just noise
potentials it's like right I mean but
it's people but there are career you
know scientists that this is what
they've done their entire lives like
lost their home and they've been through
it all right and they've and and you
know there are a few that have this this
past record of not taking the easy road
of not just going along with everyone so
for example osterholm is famous for
coming out and questioning the efficacy
of flu vaccines and so until like 2011
they this this very influential landmark
paper in The Lancet saying that you know
flu a we topped the flu vaccine but it's
actually based on kind of crappy testing
such that if you actually use better
testing it really only works you know 30
50 percent of the time and in terms of
decreasing was 30 percent now still in
favor of flu vaccines he gets it every
year but you know we we need better flu
vaccines we need to communicate to the
public what the truth is and we need to
do better and we just keep convincing
ourselves we're actually doing better
than we are we're you know that was
incredibly controversial at the time and
now it's just it's just understood and
it's kind of part of thing but I mean we
can look back in history those who are
Mavericks and really stuck to the sides
against the political winds um and and
and and you can always go to to know
they're not gonna give you the
comfortable message they're not going to
give you the message they're not going
to give you a message that they have
more certainty that that they that there
really is and they're gonna say they
don't saw is a good sick it's a good I
don't know I'm not an expert
this but let me you know show you know
the point you in the direction of an
expert in this yeah I mean I and this is
the time right if there's any other
issues any less important but this is
the time we really need the best
information um and and it's it's really
even right even for me frost presumably
but I mean we know the craziness and the
minute but it has reached a level it's
in its and it's and it's a white
division right it is a whole new thing
like oh I yeah I was I was with you
doctor burger but now you are one of the
lizard people who's gonna you know well
it's a function of this intersecting
with a lot of other issues that's
tapping into you know a repressed rage
that's just underneath the surface like
we've all seen the videos of people you
know losing it and target or you know
Trader Joe's on the whole mask thing and
how the mask thing has been politicized
and and it's concerning you know because
this shouldn't be a political issue we
should all be on the same page in terms
of how we're navigating this this is the
common interest of our society behind
right I mean this is the time to just be
extra kind and extra and to rely I mean
this should wake us up to the plight of
our essential workers who have basically
been 100 percent bottom ARF's our
society and ignored and even now ignored
are they giving hazard pay for being the
wall this is the bigger conversation
about how we're structured when we
realize that our essential workers are
you know these people who are getting
paid less than everybody else to perform
these things that are required to keep
her the gears of our society moving we
need to reform how we're treating these
people so this could be the I mean so it
is this an opportunity this is the
opportunity although yeah but but it's
yet it's bringing the best and worst and
I'm afraid at this point the worst is
overtaking there was some beautiful best
at the beginning the clapping for the
health care workers and I mean on the
singing oh but
yeah but though they ends and and yeah
there's a half-life on that stuff but I
remain optimistic and we're gonna land
this plane I think I think you know
listen get your sleep eat your veggies
make sure you're getting enough vitamin
D b12 whatever it is like what else like
what are the simple things like wear
your mask in public where are you
masking public sign of respect right
because I am keeping you safe that's
what the math says I care about you and
if there's one thing we need right now
in society is more messages I care about
my fellow human being
mm that's a good place to end it I think
I love you my friend thank you so much
ah come back anytime I think we should
do a check in every six months well the
at the rate that you're cranking these
books out you're gonna you're gonna be
back here in next month the book is
called how to survive a pandemic it's
out now in audio book and an e-book
right the workers coming out when in the
fall August 16th on August 16th oh yeah
soon amazing man so pick it up Amazon oh
it's on your is it you get it was
honoring your website we doing cool
thank you all right
[Music]